in yesterday's episode we told you all
about the free games coming to
Playstation Plus but those aren't the
only freebies you can grab in April Xbox
Amazon and the epic game store have all
revealed their list of games that can be
redeemed for zero extra dollars let's
start with the epic game store because
these games are available right now to
claim and unlike Amazon and Xbox epic
doesn't require any active subscriptions
to get the games on offer from now until
April 6th at 8am Pacific Time 11 A.M
Eastern you can claim tunji and The
Silent Age a gorgeous hand-drawn action
game Tunechi has brawler-esque side
scrolling combat and a roguelike
progression system it takes place in the
Amazon rainforest and features five
characters with different abilities and
skill trees plus you can play the game
Solo or co-op with friends meanwhile The
Silent Age is a point-and-click
adventure set in a post-apocalyptic
world next week's free games are blazing
sales a pirate themed Battle Royale game
and Dying Light enhanced Edition this
Survival game just received a sequel
last year so if you haven't played the
original next week is your chance to add
it to your library for free and speaking
of next week that's when Amazon's
freebies will be available for Prime
subscribers this list includes a
whopping 15 free games throughout April
including beloved titles like
Wolfenstein the New Order Metal Slug 4
and iced wind Dale Wolfenstein the New
Order is arguably the most notable free
game of the bunch Prime members can
claim the excellent first person shooter
starting on April 6th once claimed
you'll receive a DRM free code that can
be redeemed on Gog originally released
in 2014 Wolfenstein New Order rebooted
the iconic Series in style some might
even say it has some of the best writing
and storytelling within a genre near the
end of the month metroidvania fans
should absolutely check out Grime this
side-scrolling action adventure takes
cues from Dark Souls with its
challenging methodical combat system its
large interconnected World unique weapon
system gorgeous 2.5 D visuals and wide
variety of baddies May Grime one of the
best Souls like metroidvanias around and
that brings us to Xbox the Xbox games
with gold lineup for April have been
officially announced by Microsoft and
you can look forward to out of space
couch Edition and peaky blinders
Mastermind out of space couch Edition
will be available from April 1st to the
30th and it's a game where you play as a
captain of a cozy spaceship where you'll
need to manage your resources while
strategically dealing with a deadly
alien infestation and if you're feeling
social you'll be able to play with
friends as you explore the cosmos peaky
blinders Mastermind is based on the hit
TV series that stars Batman villain
Cillian Murphy as Tommy Shelby
birmingham's ruthless Crime Boss you'll
be able to control six key members of
the Shelby family each with different
strengths and weaknesses as you uncover
a plot to put the Shelby's out of
business set before the events of the
first season of the show show geeky
blinders Mastermind will be available
April 16th to May 15th let me know in
the comments which games you're excited
to claim in April we'll see you tomorrow
foreign